تُظهر لقطات كاميرا الجسم التي تم إصدارها مؤخرًا أن
الملازم كوري بروكس من شرطة سالزبوري بولاية نورث كارولينا وهو يسحب
سائقًا فاقدًا للوعي من مقطورة جرار محترقة، وكان
الوقود يتسرب
على الطريق على الطريق السريع في
الحريق من أسفل الشاحنة الذي كان يتبع
عددًا قليلًا من الأشخاص الذين شاهدهم بروكس يركضون نحو
حرق السيارة بدون تردد
وسحب السائق من الكابينة
جيدًا أنا أخرجه أفكر
بهذه الطريقة إذا انفجر هل سأقود بسرعة
أم
سأموت من الحرق البطيء
ساعدت سائقة مجهولة
بروكس في سحب السيارة  رجل عبر حارتين على الطريق السريع
بينما أستمر في الاطمئنان عليه،
لا أعرف من هي
لكنها كانت مثل شريكتي، لقد
ساعدتني جيدًا وكانت توجه
حركة المرور وظلت تتفقد السائق
للتأكد من أنه بخير
[موسيقى]
وفقًا للشرطة،
استعاد السائق وعيه لاحقًا وتم
نقله إلى مستشفى المنطقة،
ووصفت شرطة سالزبوري
تصرفات بروك بأنها أجنبية بطولية.